[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i can't wait forever i'm not that
patient i got too many things to do
you're comfy like a sweater but when
[Music]
is
that is
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
i can't wait forever
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody welcome back to the
stream
hey
angel is that how you say your name
sorry if i'm butchering names angel fert
hello maria hi nice to have you back
hey baggy hey mark grump and hey
princess letters hey jade how you doing
i thought i would
start this stream by singing a little
song uh before we get into the horrors
of alan wake and
i get very angry again cause i got very
angry in the last stream and i'm
probably gonna get angry again today so
let's have a chill one and just chill
out for a bit
[Music]
two years
and you still look the same
[Music]
white blinking eyes can be the same way
[Music]
do my lips take you back
to do
[Music]
do my lips make you miss me
too
tell me if the ears are all
gone
[Music]
still in love with the sun
[Music]
they still keep counting my sins
[Music]
will your heart ever forgive my
sins
[Music]
how many more first kisses
[Music]
are you gonna watch me
pick up the pieces
[Music]
i know you missed the firing by
browse
[Music]
and i could be in your arms now
tell me if the years
[Music]
do you still keep counting my sins
[Music]
will your heart ever forgive my skin
[Music]
tell me if the ears are all
gone
[Music]
do you still keep counting myself
[Music]
and how do i when
to the first boy who left me a flame
[Music]
does your heart still remember my
name
[Music]
thanks for subscribing mayo
[Music]
that is a little song that i
started to play recently it's um called
from me the moon by live l a b
lav
let's see who we have here
i miss playing the uke yeah you know
what i was going to play that song on
the guitar and then i was like you know
what let's go back to the uke let's go
back to the good old uke
oh thank you
was that the end a remix
oh what the thank you for subscribing
maybe maybe
thank you everybody hey clay hey giandio
yeah yeah
yes
what are you doing
antoine jackson years
ears sounds like veneers yaks veneers
you're all my teeth my white pristine
fake teeth
ah
the sub jungle sub jungle
yuke did its job sounds nice thank you
maria um let's put it back now
all right
and
get back to the spooky scares i'm a bit
cold but i'm thinking that playing a
horror game is gonna
nice and keep me nice and toasty warm
warm toasty because i'm gonna be
freaking out
and usually that makes me sweat
let's get into it hey kevin
so peaceful just what i needed ah i
think you did it's cute
um okay right let's do this let's get
into the game i've made you wait long
enough sweaty palms
uh something something something palms
are sweaty mom's spaghetti
should show up in a minute for you lads
and ladets and everyone else here okay
spooky spooky are you ready for the
recap
let's do the recap hello useless mug
what a name let's do the recap
previously on alan wake alice has been
kidnapped
please help me alice you'll do exactly
what i say if you ever want to see your
wife again i can't tell anyone except my
agent barry damn it barry the killer
you're my best friend and i'm worried
that that lamp the ransom is amazing
[Music]
you didn't mention the dog where's the
dog good girl oh yeah she was like
being taken over by spooky lady who gave
us the keys get her hands on the
manuscript anyway i don't know she's
resourceful i told you you were too hard
on her
listen i found out all sorts of
interesting stuff while i was digging
around
yeah mr wake it's sheriff breaker we
have an fbi agent here agent nightingale
fbi
he's
anxious to see you you'd better come to
the station okay i'll be right over
sheriff
is he i hope he's not possessed as well
help you folks name's randolph i'm the
manager we're looking for rose works as
a waitress down at the diner rose sure
nice girl
who wants to know i'm eleanor famous
writer writer who she loves heard on the
radio you were visiting well i'll show
you her trailer oh wait wait i'm putting
on my jumper it's a nice girl always
pays a rent on time are you limping are
you okay so
i found all sorts of weird stuff from
the local newspapers archives this place
is crazy disappearances mysterious
deaths urban legends come true
and get this
most of this stuff takes place around
cauldron lake
well you ain't wrong mister the indians
thought the lake was a doorway to the
underworld
i'm the god-fearing type myself i i
don't hold with that sort of thing yeah
okay
anyway
there was an island there owned by a guy
called thomas zayn thanks for coming
back you have a nice evening to be a
famous writer but i ran a bunch of
searches couldn't find a single thing he
wrote
zayn was heavily into diving so much so
that was famous
diver's isle but the volcano under the
lake erupted in 1970 and zayn went down
with the island
what
okay so i guess he was famous at the
time but nobody made copies of his
writing of his famous words and then he
went down with some pokemon
wow this place is extremely echoey where
did my
oh there you go okay
hey jeff
yeah how about that it was there in the
morning as if it had fallen from the sky
but it would take a tornado a little or
something like that
we're damn lucky it didn't crush any of
the trailers
wait what how did it it fell out of the
sky what are you talking about
[Music]
let's see what they got on today granny
claws clam chowder sparkling river
special asgardian chicken parmesan
cauldron like deep fried plate and zany
fried chicken chicken fried steak i'm
just looking what i'm gonna eat for
dinner
rabbit food
they call the salads rabbit food we got
things to do
fine fine fine let's go let's go rudolph
geez
where are we going then i have to wait
for you now you're just hovering along
is that noise that knocking is that his
leg is it like wooden or something
does he have a wooden leg
it gets better a local girl barbara
jagger drowned in cauldron lake just a
week earlier they were lovers
sure jagger's a local spook store the
scratch and hag comes for you in the
dark childish stuff like that oh is that
anything maybe that's what the woman i'm
just maybe that's the woman's heart all
who give us the keys about this stuff
were written by cynthia weaver i asked
around and she's that crazy bag lady you
met
what the lamp lady she can be a little
oh shy
yeah anyway
she knows so much
before they both died and she had some
kind of a breakdown
oh wow okay
so she does know a lot
she has reasons to be scared she knows
she knows things say with this
yeah
well mister this here's rose's trailer
you mind me asking what you want with
her we're just here to talk to her pal
thank you
rudolph
i mean i'm here to talk but i don't know
about you you've been a bit creepy with
her to be honest
uh useless mug says you played the hell
out of this game in high school but you
only just realized that the voice actor
for alan wake
uh
especially the narration is a little bit
over the top
what is he
welcome to
i mean this whole story is over the top
mr wake
i'm
i'm so glad you're here you don't sound
like this you have my manuscript oh
oh yes
please come in oh yes
so glad to sleep
this is really good
rose yes my manuscript yeah she's she's
hypnotized
i thought she was like i need a muse to
inspire you oh for barry
she doesn't have anything yeah uh
yeah what's
oh barry
what
did he drink too
oh yeah he did
no
it's coming for you
hiding in my barber's skin
i'm too weak to stop it you must turn
the lights on
i promised i'd come visit you
and your lovely wife
you must finish what you started
but he can't right some supernatural
force is stopping him
you must turn the lights on okay
oh what a cute little room
i felt nauseous hungover oh my gosh
this is her bedroom
she's so obsessed with him look but it
seems i have an imaginary editor to help
me
she's an old woman in a funeral dress i
call her barbara jagger she's very
strict i'm writing faster and faster
my manuscript is being heavily wrong
the edits are getting very aggressive
and each day there's less of me and more
of her i hate it but i know she's right
she promises me i can save alice this
way she knows more of this than i do
about the complex incantation i'm
attempting about this place
she's worked with another writer under
similar circumstances the one that died
the genre of the story seems to be
shifting it's turning into a horror
story i'm getting close i can feel it
i just hope you don't die in some sort
of volcano eruption afterwards or
something
believe in change
oh i said she was a positive person
she really did love him
why does she have this mobile
i guess like i can't really
i can't really say anything i still
sleep with the teddy bears
so what i guess we just don't grow up
these things a day for me i had less
than 12 hours left to meet the kidnapper
all i could do was get barry into the
car work something out once i got on the
road
barry was out of it he was way too heavy
to carry
can you help me carry barry please
i deserve more money
i'm still
handsome welcome to the oh dear diner
what can i get you today
coffee no i couldn't work up much hate
for rose something had used her to get
to me and left its mark
first refill is free
milk and sugar on the counter there
would you like to hear today's specials
oh thank you
a nice day i guess we're just gonna go
soon
my gun and flashlight were gone i'd have
to find a way to get barry into the car
as quickly as possible there was no time
to waste how am i going to get him
maybe i'll get ruled off to help me
let's read this mr randolph like rose
that little smile she had how she was
still sweet when life had tried so hard
to make her bitter
it wasn't any of this business what she
did in her trailer but those strangers
the writer and his smart ass sidekick
looked like trouble and they've been in
there for hours way past her normal
bedtime he reached for the phone
station she's not five but okay
he reached for the oh okay right so the
police are on their way brilliant
perfect they're gonna think this is
really suspicious
uh can we go on any of these likely not
doesn't look like it
i just stepped outside to catch a breath
of fresh air let me tell you
the weather's getting heavy
nights like this make me especially glad
i'm here talking to you and not home in
bed once once the weather takes a turn
like this i can't sleep at all it's all
tangled bed sheets and dark thoughts
punctuated by the occasional plunge into
nightmare
is it just me
well perhaps it is but i hope i can make
the night a little bit easier to get
through calmer you're on kbf fm
hey hi
what's on your mind walt
well
i ain't the way you are bud
well
like a man with a problem well
yeah
yeah
i had a
you know
argument with danny
you know
oh
yeah because these are the people that
had a fight
and that's why he got sent to cell
there's something like that
yeah well you know he's uh
you
they let me know
today
and now i'm just alone here at the
window you know waiting
and there's something in the air tonight
man
i was just outside looking up at the sky
above our broadcast tower thinking the
same thing
what are you waiting for walt
i don't know
i you know something's gonna happen
you know i gotta
i think i better go
well that's a creepy song
okay
how are we gonna get army out of that
house when he's just a slump on the
floor
hello
coffee could help
give us a little bit of a
pep in our step
i don't think we can get into any of
these other caravan things
can i go into anybody's cam
what are they caravans not they're not
camper vans no they're caravans
wow that looks like a fancy one probably
not
someone's watching tv in the oh
here he is
but i'm still gonna look around because
because why not i always need stuff
gosh i last episode
was so freaking
hard and i just didn't have enough stuff
on me i didn't have enough ammunition
and i didn't have enough batteries it
was horrible so if i can find anything
here now before i move on it would be
splendid oh you're gonna get it now oh
great
cops are just there
bye maria thanks for coming this is
agent nightingale fbi get him up
hemingway you're under arrest you move a
muscle all alone right now goddamn face
stay right where you are
damn matrix moves
and we were taking the mick out of him
last episode i'll take it all back
what
damn sorry my computer were weird
i thought it crashed but it didn't we're
all good we're all good my computer just
couldn't handle i don't want to matrix
my appointment
come on
no
i can't
i must save my wife
look his stamina has gotten better
oh
no no it hasn't no hasn't lies
oh i'm sure you did mark i'm only uh
third episode in so you probably did get
this far
no i'm not here i'm not here
one man
why did i say that
uh just keep going
am i supposed to use this it's like
leverage i think so i'd
cover all right catch your breath dude
catch your breath let go
catch breath
go
catch breath go
go go go go go go go go
you were never very good at cross
country where are you alan but now you
have to be
i can't believe they're shooting at him
already like they have not seen him do
anything they've just seen him run what
the hell
ah
for dinner i guess running doesn't make
him look good
barbra jagger's skin slept faithfully in
the dark place that was its home and
prison
it was hungry and in pain
it dreamed of its nights of glory when
the poet's writing had called it from
the depths and given it a brief terrible
taste of power and freedom
the rock stars had stirred it from the
deep sleep the poet had sunk it back
oh that's so freaking cool so it's like
like a sleeping demon or something and
it gains power from
from poets or creators or writers
um because obviously it can it like
channels itself through them
that's cool
but it says
um
called from the depths and given it a
brief terrible taste of power and
freedom
it dreamed of its nights of glory when
the poet's writing had called it from
the depths and given it a brief terrible
the rock stars
had stirred it from
[Music]
that was weird
thank you for subscribing amx td
thank you
uh
i had started from the deep sleep the
poet had sunk it back
too in the end the rock stars had stared
it from the deep sleep
okay so someone had like
it uses creatives to get power but also
a poet had sunk it back
to its doop sloop
so maybe alan wake can fight against
this thing
and not do what it says
barbara
that's her name right
whoa
okay thanks barbara i'm guessing that
was you
uh um that wasn't me that was
what the frick
did you see that
going on night deputies tell me he's
fired and wait and he didn't have a gun
you almost test a billion instead come
over here
i don't have time for this
we'll make the time can't just go junior
people in my
yeah it's true it's true they did just
start shooting
i'm glad they addressed this
good
is there a piece of paper over here or i
see something very bright shiny yeah
rose didn't know how the strange old
lady got in her trailer and she looked
wrong somehow
the woman showed her teeth in an
approximation of a smile and traced a
finger down rose's cheek pretty girl she
said
rose felt as if she was falling asleep
the crown spoke in a whisper
her words ice cold and dark in rose's
ear
okay so that's how she got
possessed or whatever it was
entranced
godzilla arky imagine just random a
random godzilla appears that would be
kind of cool
okay it doesn't like there's anything
down here
but i have recent checkpoint everybody
whoo celebrations
okay let's get up in the like yay i love
you
[Music]
i've reached another checkpoint what
oh there's a flare
that's great
now we have to worry about real cops as
well as probably shadow people
over here
nope nope nope nope not me not me not me
what's the [ __ ]
what's happening
i want to see what's happening
i don't know
but it broke my light
is anything over here this horror was
everywhere i went circling me
the cops didn't stand a chance they were
after a writer not a monster
[Laughter]
he wears a tweed jacket come on
it could be bigfoot i mean
it freaking tore down a bloody tree so
you know
it could be
can we see it
the trees are actually quite sparse
oh it's gonna bring down another
helicopter oh hello ally alive
hey
uh i'll hide here
i'm scared
i'm scared
oh it's the birds
that's a big explosion that's the mighty
big explosion this is so cinematic i
love it
i have this frogger dog says they have a
theory and what it is but they don't
want to spoil it if it's right
well i mean if you don't know
then say it but if anyone does know then
don't say whether frog or doggo is right
or not
i mean you don't have to say if you
don't want to say it obviously but don't
worry it's not spoilers if it's just
speculation you don't actually know
is there something through here
well i think i can also go up here so
i'm gonna go up here first
oh we could have watched the explosion
through here
oh that would have been so much more fun
oh wow
oh what's that over there
coffee
nothing
more useful
coffee in here too
hey
go ahead mulligan over
uh we got wheeler and rose here
wheeler's drunk or hopped up on
uh
i don't have anything on that deputy
mulligan over
well whatever
anyway rose is just being playing weird
here you better get doc in and take a
look okay at least they haven't started
shooting at our partners
quickly the uh vet's gonna want to
interview the wheeler over
oh yeah
okay so he's all good oh we cannot see
this one maybe
ye
see what we can see
i could see the lights at the radio
station in the distance
oh that is the radio station yeah
kind of reminds me of a what's that
podcast
there's like a podcast that i used to
listen to and it's kind of like a
spooky-ish podcast it's it's kind of
sci-fi
yeah way more sci-fi um
and it's someone on the radio and
they're talking about like strange
sci-fi things happening in the town
what's that oh nightmail welcome to
night vale that's what it's called
i am there pretty cool
tower in the distance was part of the
local radio station maine seemed like a
decent guy perhaps he could give me
directions to the coal mine
yeah seems nice enough and apparently
doesn't sleep so we're good there
unnatural shadows clung to the gate the
darkness that was after me was trying to
stop me i wouldn't get through without
life
oh
that's very big light
what's over here there should be coffee
here somewhere there
[Music]
uh is this the game for way back or
remake this is actually the game from
way back
oh i have to fix it how
uh yeah i saw the
remaster
on pc and i honestly think the old
version looks nicer the remaster was way
like
more contrasted um which i think just
just
i don't know i just like the wishy-washy
look of like
like sand hill games and like this game
i just think having like an overly
overly contrasted crisp look kind of
takes away from any
ambiguous
visuals
which i think looks nice in horror games
yes this is the original the og i think
the tags will say it's a remake because
i just clicked whatever was that
um
was the uh
recommended tag so i'll fix them later
but
this is the og game it's quite pretty
isn't it
oh god
i've got to kick it again i guess
that's like that's how you fix things
people
or am i missing something is there
something else i need to do
no it's fine
yeah
oh wow
maybe next time we'll get it
oh there you go
done
[Music]
i'd still have preferred a flashlight
because then i can take it with me and
feel safe
looks like i don't get that luxury so
we'll just continue without it i suppose
yeah exactly sydney i mean this is pc i
think the remaster would probably look
like way better on consoles for instance
but i think the pc just it still holds
up really well
watching this is a good way to spend my
night after a full day of classes and
being sick not gonna lie
well that's good gentee i'm glad at
least you're gonna have some fun with us
i'm really sorry to hear that you're
being sick and stuff though that that
really sucks i know how that feels like
i was sick on monday as well so it
freaking sucks um but it's nice you can
chill out now at least
hopefully you'll feel better tomorrow
fingers crossed
[Applause]
i don't i don't know
oh of course
of course
but but what about
a gun do i not get a gun
ah
i'm just gonna look back here for
again any gun
no
surely not
i wonder if i can do this without
boosting oh i can
yeah
okay we're gonna try our best to save
the batteries this time
i thought that that you couldn't
actually break through their like
darkness barriers without boosting but
you can it just takes a long long time
to recognize
they were an ideal weapon for my
situation
straight away
you know
this is
everyone's gone
come on
[Music]
where am i gone now
i have a last path
come on
come on mr wakey wakey wakey no [ __ ] off
you little wall what come on
i love the light i love the light i love
i love love love love the light haha
screw you [ __ ]
see didn't even have to kill it
and here's another call
you're on kbfm with pat main
it's no peabody pat
what's on your mind milt
well i live near the trailer park pat
and there's a big ruckus going on over
there
well that's just up the road for me too
what's going on do you know
i don't know but there's a bunch of
police cars there lots of sirens uh
helicopters buzzing around that's where
i am gunshots
gunshots
yes sir like from abyssal so can you
find out what's going on
because it's just next door and they're
popping off guns there
they're still shooting
no it was maybe 10-15 minutes ago it
sounds serious pat i'm telling you it
don't sound like no party
well i'm certainly gonna give the
station a call milt
okay
you'll hear it here as soon as i hear
from them
okay thanks i'm on my way too
uh now i say why young does not see my
comments lol third world guy here
jefferson what what do you mean i i just
cannot see all the comments because i
don't want to play the game
but i saw i saw you coming
okay
oh for [ __ ] sake
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
[Music]
ah big rock big rock get away
[ __ ] you
what am i doing right
oh my god he's charging i don't have a
gun i hate this i know i could just use
the flashbang i refuse for one [ __ ]
person i'm gonna have to do it now okay
oh jesus
oh [ __ ] off there's loads of them now
where'd they come from
oh we all died together
this isn't darling
okay
[Music]
it's just like do a backflip
i don't think alan i don't know if you
watched the last episodes but alan's um
not the most um how would i take it
get out of his way alan
did he die oh [ __ ] yeah
okay
can we get up oh
i thought i could climb up here and find
some goodies
although i was about to miss a page
how dare i
touched by the dark presence touched by
the dark presence rose was lost in a
dreamland where everything was drawn in
black and gray crayons the old lady had
promised her that all her wishes would
come true she would be alan wake's muse
she was smiling so hard it hurt her face
she crushed a bottle full of sleeping
bells into the coffee
down inside she was screaming in terror
that's my reaction
okay
where is the gun
it's not this way because i went this
way before
i lost
no no i didn't actually
oh god
though [ __ ] off you know [ __ ] bricks
come on alan
come on out on i'm going the wrong way
now
getting confused about which way i'm
going
alan
my whole play first that's me shouting
can you [ __ ] off please
i said please
oh my god
oh get in there get in there
so much for me saving them i literally
can't save them
okay
chestnut then in the dark
apart from the little lights
yay got to play got some batteries
but i still want a gun no i want a gun
just never in the dark walk in the light
why did i do this generator
did it put oh that's a lie
okay i feel better now
all right
let's go
please sirens [ __ ] that we're going to
stay away from that
now
now
how do i have
no
no god yeah i don't understand
was this [ __ ] game
game's like lol
good luck not having anything to defend
yourself with
ah okay
what's this oh it's a log love logs
oh [ __ ] off you little [ __ ]
i will kill you with my flashlights
oh god i need batteries
ah
oh [ __ ] off you just flair did nothing
to you
oh [ __ ] off right okay fine you are [ __ ]
this
now i'm empty are you happy now i'm
empty
[Music]
something
well
well thank you very much for that uh
compassionate viewpoint lorna
there he is
hello sir do you have here's a little
surprise the famous writer alan wake
just walked in folks i'm gonna see if i
can talk him into an interview
come on in mr wake how did you do that
is that an automatic door
oh i'm so glad you could find the time
to do this mr awake
[Music]
what the hell's the matter with you
there's a civilian in there
oh i'm working with the people who made
alien isolation
although i had fallen off so many cliffs
it was ridiculous that's what you get
for naming a book the sudden stop it was
probably good i hadn't had the chance to
tell maine where i was going i'd have to
lose the cops and my own way to the mine
but first
let's read this stare through the broken
studio window into the dark woods he
turned around started to walk out but
maine grabbed his arm young man you
almost shot me you don't shoot off
rounds at people like that no you died
with you
nightingale shook his arm free marched
out his cheeks burned with rage and
humiliation oh i hope he's gonna be okay
out here
i hope we get to see him again then
maybe
maybe sometime in the future and he'll
like help us out or something
i hope so
oh really i really
don't understand how i'm supposed to do
all this without
without weapons
oh my god
i want to get the ammo away just hold on
just one moment
just one moment
oh [ __ ] off your [ __ ]
ah
can't see can't see trees everywhere
okay
okay
good good
oh that was handy
okay good
right when i needed it
i heard them out there
bye jefferson thank you for coming
you have a good one too
ah
[Music]
i can see them all in the distance
are they there too no i'm i'm honestly
thinking every [ __ ] shadow is one of
them
i'm gonna say by here i'm saving the
light i'm saving alive
what they like literally disappear when
you go back into the light
okay
[Music]
oh [ __ ] up
oh great
i don't know what to do with you can i
kill you without shooting you
can just bash you in the head
nope
there was no sensible reason for the
power company work lights to be here it
was almost as if they'd been left for
someone like me to use
the darkness controls the taken
okay
i know [ __ ]
yes
[Music]
oh [ __ ] jesus christ now
okay oh gosh that's a lot of people
oh my god
i'm definitely gonna die oh [ __ ]
oh this game
look at him he's still catching his
breath in there okay let's just get out
get out
oh die everybody stop [ __ ] getting
around my
oh god
oh god
can't see cassie
oh [ __ ] oh
i find this game so difficult i should
have played on easy this is like [ __ ]
hard as [ __ ]
hello
no no no
it has come from everywhere i need to
get a good like stance like i did last
time where i could just like back up
and keep
using my flashlight on them but first i
need to throw this
okay so maybe if i come back here
i know they're on the sides of me as
well so i'm very aware of that ah but
it's ah
every time you turn around there's a
[ __ ] bush in your [ __ ] face
oh god i think i'm out of amount of uh
places to go
i need to run back the other way come on
come on
come
on a little [ __ ] stick i'm not banned oh
[ __ ]
oh god
come on there's just one lap
ah
okay
yes right we did that
that was very difficult i'd give myself
a pat on the back big button
okay and off we go um
what
what
i could have done
that would have helped me so much
what
oh my gosh i cannot believe that look i
couldn't just turned on this bloody
light it wouldn't have stayed on by the
looks of it but oh my god that would
have helped me so much
you know what i did it without the light
no [ __ ] off there's not gonna be more of
them shut up
i can't believe that though
what the hell
oh come on allen
darkness consistency
okay so there's nothing else here
where do we go
is there something up here
on this page
love some hindsight
yeah hindsight is beautiful flank
the bulldozer's engine roared to life
mud and rocks flew as it fought for
traction it crashed the concrete wall
and landed heavily in the yard if it
were an animal that would have shaken
its head after the impact fixed its eyes
on me and charged
of course it had no head nor eyes
shadows crawled on its form twisting it
into a monster then it came for me
okay we have a lot to look forward to by
the sounds of it
and uh alan you're gonna have to run i'm
tired you're just gonna have to run
i know you're not very good at that but
yeah gonna have to get better at it
because your life depends on it
well you [ __ ] off with all these little
shady things i want to keep on turning
in the light
i hate how slow he is
we are in this is urgent okay
where are we supposed to go
not up here idiot
uh
just keep going down there there's a
page there
okay
sarah trusted her gut and her gut said
agent nightingale was an [ __ ]
he felt wrong and it wasn't just the
smell of stale booze
it was in the way he flashed his badge
pulled rank the look in his eyes and
like shots at everybody
what was this about an accident where
was his wife and most importantly why
did she let weight go
he wouldn't answer her questions federal
business was all he'd say
[Music]
[Music]
okay
yellow missed away cam
the most stubborn man i've ever met
alice alice
alice i'm here
i'm so alone
it's all gonna go to hell
you need to be careful to cooperate
that's weird she didn't say that
had been terrible but that wasn't the
only thing that hadn't been right with
the call she sounded wrong somehow
but she had called me
and i can hear her breathing again
in my ears something is so wrong the
pipe wrenched itself loose from the
bridge's steel framework
wrapped in darkness it floated in midair
twitching
for a moment i didn't understand what i
was looking at the heavy object lurched
at me with impossible force i threw
myself out of the way but just barely
when i turned my flashlight on it it
shook in a dark rage before it flew at
me again
spooky flying objects
[Music]
railway bridge up ahead and a warehouse
of some sort on the opposite shore i
hoped i could find a car from there
well first of all i saw a little yellow
arrow so we're gonna go up here
see i can always hear her breathing
when we follow the yellow arrows as well
is that supposed to mean that
there's stuff like something else going
on like we're in his head like is he in
some sort of coma or something happened
like something traumatic happened to him
in his real life and then he's making up
this fictional world to deal with it i
don't i don't know something is
happening here
thank you very much i appreciate all of
this
see we can hear her breathe
oh my god this is lovely i'm i love this
that was a jump scare
but i killed them all with one flashbang
so that's good
it's like here's those goodies and now
some batters
i can still hear her breathing you can
hear it too right it's not just me
oh
gentee
i think that's how you say it
uh follow follow
follow okay yeah yeah uh you'll have to
get used to this he gets out of breath
with like any movement
so you're just you just have to get used
to it
we all have had to get used to this the
darkness that was pursuing me was
growing stronger and it was taking over
everything
i don't know what i'm supposed to do
here
ah
jesus
you're about your [ __ ] jesus what the
[ __ ] is that bubble
i'm getting bubbles
i'm getting probably by the bridge
hey eternal cheese cake
what a name
i love them just like hey
okay cool
the darkness that was pursuing me was
growing stronger and it was taking
forever
okay i'm gonna have to like
instead of just try and run through i'm
gonna have to actually
yeah here we go
oh god oh god
i'm stuck in a [ __ ] corner mate
what how did it get me
[ __ ] all of that crap
i'm out
i'm outtie
no
playing field
not the wheelbarrow
what
what is happening
i'll let him catch his breath while we
do something shut right in his smug face
he pleaded for me to open the door true
to form the [ __ ] actually thought i
would obey
i had no sympathy left no guilt either
not for him
i took a moment to savor the scream
i bet i had a smile on my face it was
all that i had time for the dark
presence was inside the lodge with me
who do we think he's talking about oh i
guess that um officer who's a bit of a
prick
maybe he killed the dog if he did then
fair enough you know i'm all with you
allen let him let him rot
probably didn't as a teenager just
started to get interested in writing
stephen king had been a source of
inspiration to me oh yeah i thought
about all the inanimate objects that had
come to life in his books
no one is safe in a good horror story
certainly not the protagonist that's
what makes them fun this was anything
but
the darkness could possess anything and
it was getting closer
heavy judy
heavy duty
hmm
hello
i hear you i'm just going to get my
coffee
i don't want any trouble
are you barrel safe
i don't trust barrels now
yes these
okay what i've watched my limit
that's wreck
okay
here we go
no
i did not did you
loses
[ __ ] i'm a loser
oh [ __ ] off you don't shy
this was anything but
the darkness could possess anything and
it was getting closer
oh yeah
did we
we did swap the big one no we didn't
okay let's do that
heavy duty heavy-duty
[Music]
duty go get the coffee
can we jump up here and go up here
i wonder if there's a place that we can
go where they wouldn't get me
that would be nice
probably not though
okay
so what we're going to do
is we're going to
use up our revolver ammo
so that we can replace it
oh god get out the [ __ ] way
oh [ __ ] hell it died even quicker
okay this was anything but
the darkness could possess anything yes
it was getting closer come on i don't
care
hold down e please
there
oh can we go up here wait is that what
that's where we just were
uh okay
i'm just not very good when i let them
get around me because they are very good
like the ai is very good at circling you
so maybe i need to like try and head
over here or or behind there obviously i
could do that
hey karen
these people are getting angry because i
go 9-1-1 but i didn't call 9-1-1 i swear
who
oh god i didn't do my plans
[ __ ] off you that [ __ ] thick oh god
oh
god oh god
oh god
okay
[Music]
okay
yeah baby
oh i still got mate
okay
yay
don't forget this one
okay can we go now please i don't like
these
noises let's go in there
[ __ ]
oh jesus i bite you all
no i don't want it there's a writing
under the stand
i screamed so much at this game i can't
even there was some writing under the
stairs i feel like we need to go back
down and read the facts of our existence
for granted unaware that they are merely
a thin veneer of desperate self-delusion
covering the vast cosmos of madness
and horror
oh it's another episode of our favorite
channel my very favorite show let's go
watch it
excuse me
tonight's episode
of family occasion
journalist alvin derl's trip to study
the local customs of an insular
community in knight springs has been
less than successful
until tonight
well i'm glad you changed your minds
about this ancient customs local
mythology my editor loves this kind of
stuff well mr derleth we don't want to
feel like we're on exhibition but you
have demonstrated the seriousness of
your intent oh i am seriously annoying
do your thing i'll stay out of your way
and observe actually i thought you could
assist us i'm afraid the twilight zone
it's kind of like that
intimate perspective
of course
well i guess that's the least i
what would i have to do
what would i have to do
with a kiss
no thank you
oh my god this is awkward
what are we watching
oh
oh i see you should she'd be like poison
ivy
oh no
something
body shall else his thousand years
but mythology is so cool though such
quests always bear fruit
[Music]
in the night springs
okay so i see you're all telling me
about red barrels are there red barrels
in this game and i just have not even
noticed them
where are they i can hear
i can hear them over here i don't like
that
in light you can hurt them
yeah i i know oh really i came back down
to see that
i guess the barrels were outside
they're gone now at least that's good
oh i thought it was gonna give me some
stuff down here
i guess not
so
oh my god the big red ones [ __ ] yeah
okay
well now i know
i'll keep an eye out
try and get me up here beach
okay i can still hear them running
around doing some weird stuff
they're probably just
getting really confused being like i
want to follow but it's light and i
don't like the light
what do i do
okay let's continue the game
thank you for the heads up
the darkness surged towards me sucking
everything loose from the ground into
its depths tugging at my clothes i saw
the flare the kidnapper had dropped and
threw myself towards it just as i felt
my feet lead the ground
the darkness embraced me with the force
of a tornado somehow i managed to light
the flare the darkness roared and cast
me away i fell toward the dark waters of
the lake far below okay so that's gonna
be the end of this chapter
so we're gonna get near
the kidnapper again
jesus christ that scared me
oh why any red bowels here
i don't see any i don't see any am i
being stupid oh i can't jump over that
there's going to be a big boss fight or
something
the ball's over
no
oh no
get out of the [ __ ] way little dick
right
oh this is going to be hard as
i saw dozer i'm already dead
oh jesus okay where can i go
um
gotta stay by the edges i guess maybe if
i try and go back here where yeah stay
back here
because they're all gonna spawn at the
edges
and maybe if i can stick
but then i might oh my god corning
ah today i'm just gonna have to see
just gonna have to see what happens
hope for the best
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
oh [ __ ] jesus christ
oh jeez geez
ah gotta reload gotta reload gonna
reload gotta reload gotta reload gotta
reload gonna get away from the people
oh my god okay just gotta use my flares
okay gotta use more flares
oh gosh wait
stock up first
don't need anything yeah okay
gonna be a little gotta be a little
[Music]
got it
oh i'm still alive
oh wow hmm
okay stay behind
these so that you can't bulldoze me
if i can
okay i've got the flares
come on then
oh [ __ ] off this of course
it just boulders right there
oh [ __ ] off
i thought that was gonna be static for
some reason
ah
no no no
no no come on
oh my god move
[ __ ] jesus move
i want more flares but you know this
will do it i suppose
oh my god
such [ __ ] at running
such a little [ __ ] aren't you such a
little [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh
whoa that frame rate what
okay that didn't work
okay can i get here please
come on come on open the thing don't
catch your breath back
open the [ __ ] thing oh my god
i'm so pissed off right now
open that thing open it oh my god just
open the [ __ ] thing
open it
get whatever the [ __ ] you need out there
okay now go
i'm so sorry this game gets me so mad
sometimes
get the coffee
go
can we close the door behind us
we have light here
[Music]
like this is so good i'm so glad that my
stress makes you happy
yeah [ __ ] kids you can't get me in here
can you ha ha
i want to get back because
i know there's more for me to get in
here
can i kill it this way
maybe i shouldn't go back
to be fair i do have a lot of stuff
so maybe i'm okay
but still
maybe
i'm pushing my love here
okay [ __ ] go
whoa
come on come on come on oh [ __ ] off
no oh good good good good
okay i want to go back i want to get
those flares this is something there's
something i just i can't leave without
them i've got to get them
oh my god no
yes no
come on
oh hail the checkpoint
yes
[Music]
[Music]
okay
we have 10 players now
all sucked up baby
i can use the car oh
yes
there's anything in here
i had never been this glad to see the
sunrise i had a couple of hours to get
to the coal mine
the sunrise
we made it we made it
the coal mine wasn't far now
[Music]
i would meet the kidnapper and he would
give me alice i wouldn't give him any
other choice a drowning man will clutch
at a straw
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
call my museum
do i have
guys i can't
i guess i won't need it for some reason
i can't get my gun out or anything which
i'm very annoyed about because i risked
a lot to go back and get those extra
flares and it didn't matter apparently
i tried so hard this episode to make
sure that i was
preserving my ammunition
and i think i did very well
uh but the game doesn't care
basically
the game is like well you lost it all so
you should have been using it
oh wow
oh i can't i can't jump over that
because i'm i'm alan wake
he doesn't know how to mantel
oh wait he said can't wait for the
prequel allen can't wake up
then the sequel alan wakes again the
prequel is alan goes to sleep goes to
sleep
[Music]
can i use this
is there any notes or anything around
here
oh [ __ ] it you know what just just get
in yes just just go
bring bruh baby oh scheiser sorry
whosoever cars this is i don't know why
i've just picked up some random person's
car and they're probably just hiking in
the forest right now and then they come
back they're all money they can't wait
to go home and have a nice bath and that
car is gone
this thing is really difficult to drive
what the hell
it's so sensitive okay
my four-wheeler my off-road
i'm so cool
how do i get out this is something that
i couldn't figure out last time oh i
just pressed e again
well i guess that makes sense
last time
i was um also trying to kill a bunch of
people and then i was like how do i get
oh my god but it's fine
this is the radio batman and you're
listening to kbf fm folks
i want to apologize for kind of
abandoning you to that looping music
track last night but i was
you see i encountered a big shot g-man
with an itchy trigger finger who could
use a
lesson in manners and a boot in the ass
not necessarily in that order either now
folks
i know i'm not being very informative
here and i apologize for that i really
should just keep quiet but
i'm just so peeved right now because
some people just shouldn't be carrying
badges
i'm just glad that you're done
things out and if someone i met last
night is listening let me just say
i'm sorry if my mouth got you in trouble
i'm pretty sure you're not the bad guy
here godspeed son
i hope you know what you're doing
now what's that me
to me i'll be talking to dr nelson all
morning but first little music
[Music]
that that sucks
didn't do very well there
this poor thing
not doing very well with this car
trying to keep an eye out for any uh
notes
or anything
whew
[Music]
it's just getting around everywhere
four-wheel drive baby
i want to read this sign
i know it looks boring let's hey is this
where it started
[ __ ]
and literally you've just gone where i
started oh [ __ ] shoes
yeah three-point turn my ass let's go
what am i doing
um
[Music]
oh shite
oh my god
so slippy
okay this is where i was and then where
do i go
down here
not that way because that's the way i
went isn't it
it's gotta be this way
oh no that's the way it went this is
gonna be that way
back it back it up
becky dip picky dip okay let's go
[Music]
i wish there was a horn
how is he not just coming out of that
car going
can i jump in this car afterwards and
then
i can i can drive multiple cars yes alan
wake is a batter so you don't care you
should be in gta
welcome back to kbf fm hope you enjoyed
that tune
now doc you were talking about life and
finding that special someone that soul
mate well you were talking about that i
was saying i don't buy it you see
to me that's strange because i always
pegged you as a hopeless romantic
you got me there pat
but i think love's where you'll look for
it and you need to do a lot of looking
sure
but the idea that there's that one
special person out there for you and if
you miss that chance it's gone forever
and you're forever incomplete i mean
isn't that depressing yeah that's
actually massively refreshing
depression
especially the second part that you're
incomplete without someone else that's
wrong you're complete without someone
else
well no
what i am saying is that your potential
for finding that connection
isn't limited to what's essentially a
chance encounter
how is that harsh yeah well i guess
that's a nice thought but let me say
something personal here okay now well i
i don't disagree with you exactly but i
can't really fit that together with what
i feel
what i what i felt for someone because
she was the one she was and she
i let her
drift away from me
maybe i didn't put in the work i don't
know but well since then and it was a
long time ago but but since then there
hasn't been anyone not like her
and i'm not saying i dwell on her or
haven't moved on i like my life i'm not
living in the past
but i do miss the way she completed me
you can't argue with the heart pattern
uh i'm sorry folks i had kind of a scary
experience last night
feel free man
that's hard
but that woman might not even be the
same as you remember now
so she might not compete complete you in
the same way
as you felt she did before and we often
have
a way of looking at the past with like
rose tinted glasses as well should we
just carry on driving our beat up jeep
yes i think we will we're just gonna
drive this thing till we explode it
hey kenji cars
i used to watch a youtube channel back
in the day i remember chatting to you a
while back about it and as i would have
it i started working at ca two weeks ago
and see your names today at work
that is a world coincidence
that's so cool though welcome to ca i'm
sure you'll enjoy it here [ __ ] sake
i'm gonna blame that on you not my bad
driving
uh but yeah that's super super cool
awesome
we are gonna we are actually going to
explode this freaking car
oh it's gonna be crazy
oh hello can i get up there i was early
i was supposed to meet the kidnapper at
noon in the main building the cool night
is quiet it was a museum now
okay that's not as
spooky
uh please walk up the steps thank you
please walk up
i think he's running out of breath just
going up steps now
vermont spying on the writer on the
ferry had been a disappointment
his boss had made wake out to be
something special
but mod hadn't been impressed
he'd gotten a good long look of the wife
and he lost he saw
motted fantasized about going awake into
a fight but it hadn't happened
still he'd get his chance to see if the
writer had anything in him he'd been
promised as much
so matt is the kidnapper and mott likes
our wife
why
there are like so many other women out
there why take
a married woman who is married to like a
famous writer i don't understand
but sure okay
we'll go with that
she's so hopelessly beautiful
uh
so there must be another building
i guess it's the one down there because
it's very big
where's my car
there is smokey joe
um i guess we'll just follow the winning
mode
that is true lord love is a very
complicated emotion
uh and yeah actually i totally knew
about the compass and i totally forgot
about it
i have a tendency to do that i think
it's quite nice though to not rely too
much on the compass but yeah i
absolutely forgot about that if i'm
honest with you
while we were wait what while there were
some earlier residents in the area the
true genesis of the town of brightfalls
came with the founding of the bright
force mining company and the opening of
the bright force coal mine in 1878
although the work was hard and dangerous
many immigrants germans poles italians
finns and swedes among others worked the
mines
while lucrative oppressed the mining
subtly declined in the 20th century the
scenes were rich but hard to get at and
the volcanic activity in the area made
the mine shafts particularly dangerous
okay so this is where
oh wait
is this where the the first writer died
then
oh look at the little museum things
can we take that axe
i want the axe
we need something to defend ourselves
from this
mitt is that a mitt
um
with nightingale gone and the night wind
blowing in through the broken studio
window main stared at sarah
the sheriff looked away
maine's voice shook with barely
controlled anger
that boy's doing more drinking than
thinking
i hope you know what you're doing sarah
he's got a sickness in his eyes you take
my word for it he wants wake for a
reason and it's not for anything good
is it the like woman forcing him to
drink what no but she wants him to do
these things so it can't be that in 1970
a volcanic eruption below cauldron lake
um while relatively minor caused most of
the deep mining tunnels to collapse or
flood 32 miners lost their lives in the
calamity and all mining around
brightfalls came to a final stop now
many of the remaining buildings are
protected as historical landmarks
okay
[Music]
i didn't want to go outside
[Music]
cops had to be looking for me
the new sun turned the place into a
sauna
the day dragged on
different scenarios ran through my mind
ways of how i'd torture the kidnapper to
get alice back or the different horrible
things he could have done to her i
imagined her dead i had no way of
knowing she was still alive it was
killing me
i was running on blind hope
it was all a waste of time
a montage of alan wait just kicking
chairs
is back you know where mirror peak is
it's a big mountain north of where you
are you follow the path from the mine
you can't miss it there's a lookout
point there i'll be waiting i'm through
being jerked around you want to see your
wife alive because if you do you better
watch what you say to me do we
understand each other
i want to talk to alice
yeah i want the manuscript don't keep me
waiting awake
hello
hello ah
i'm gonna kill him
i had to get to mirror peak
wow jesus christ what the [ __ ] oh my god
i'm not in love with this close maybe
closer than ever before
what game why jesus
chill out
okay i guess we have to jump down here
okay let's stock up
we've got 11 players now hell yeah
okay
yeah we're all
ready to go i feel quite good
ready to die again yeah
let's go
[ __ ] sake
i didn't even press forward that was
just him falling
before anything crazy happens let's do
some reading thomas zane fell for
barbara jagger it happened fast she was
young vibrant oh
so the writer had never been a very
happy
and without any seeming effort she had
changed all that
zane felt good for the first time in his
life everything she did was another
piece of a jigsaw puzzle he hadn't even
known he'd been missing
and best of all she made the words flow
strong and sharp
she was his music
and that's what um she made that woman
say to us you know oh you just need a
muse
i've already got a revolver but thank
you
and i don't need any ammo but thank you
i do appreciate the full box of ammo
when i don't need it what the hell game
okay
wow
jesus
okay
well these hurt me too because i don't
want that oh [ __ ] sake i was trying to
get the red bow you little frix
get out of my way
come on
oh [ __ ] off [ __ ] sack right
this game brings out the worst of me
come on
i keep going there we go
we did it well done well done so good
okay let's go back
damn we only use
[ __ ]
what's this crazy
spooky guns
oh no it's so spooky
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
it's so stupid
it actually really hurts
don't touch me
oh
so weird
spooky cards
okay
hello hello i see you
i'll see you i'll see ya
hello
anything down here for me
any notes or
flash frames
nope
well let's [ __ ] just just go dude
just go just go
i don't know what's happening in there
and i don't want to find out so let's
just go
oh my god
so i need to open this with all that
happening in there
uh can you come out here
no
i don't want to go in there
there
is that is that working did that do the
thing
oh it's just spooky spooky wood and
stuff
spooky boxes
a spooky wheelbarrow
spooky cogs
spooky everything
okay fine i'll stay in here then
good i missed it
it's all good
i just stay in the room
um okay
the only way to reach the hillside ahead
was to go through the building i had to
find a way to avoid electrocution
that's what i'm supposed to be doing
can i jump on the car and then jump over
it no i feel like that's a really stupid
idea
let's go drive around see if i can see
anything maybe there's something i need
to crash into
all right
[ __ ] you boys
oh donuts
[Music]
um
come out come on
come on
[Music]
fine you know what
i'll just shoot you
oh yeah
nice
i know you're gonna blow up soon
but uh
i think i'll take my chances
nope
nope we need up nope
[ __ ] hell jesus christ mate
oh my god
i hate all this [ __ ] and moving crap and
stuff
oh my god oh that's so hard right okay
okay
oh no sign right here okay okay here's
my time just go
just go
[Music]
not coming
okay
where's the next ones because if i can
just
take them out then i can take the people
out
people surprisingly enough i know what
i'm worried about the most here
oh [ __ ] off where did you come from
oh
[ __ ]
[Music]
oh
god
what gun am i using okay use this one
where
okay
there it is
where is it
oh
just
okay
ah
okay
where now
come on run
come on
is it gonna be anymore i don't know i
don't want it
please say
please say no more
yay we made it
okay
okay
nice
we still have one of these as well which
is very handy
uh
okay we're doing all right we're doing
all right
foreign
uh
okay
okay
thank you thank you
thank you thank you
let's reload
this bad boy
okay
see what's in hands those are red vowels
i'm so glad i know about these red bells
thank you so much
no the red barrel well i guess doesn't
matter
i'm just going for the right brow but i
guess it don't matter
trust no one in the dark i know and
you've told me that so many times
writing on the wall
only trust the writing on the wall
follow
oh and read
we shall read
some of the taken retained echoes of
their former selves but these were just
the nerve twitches of a dead thing
nothing remained but a shell covered and
filled with darkness
in most cases these puppets were enough
for the purposes of the dark presence
but for anything more elaborate as with
the writer it was different
it needed his mind and so rather than
taking him over completely it merely
touched him
i'm not gonna lie i didn't really listen
to that some of them have taken the
retained echo that they form himself
in most cases these puppets were enough
for the purposes of that present but
anything more elaborate as with the
writer it was different it needed his
mind and so rather than taking him over
he really touched him okay okay okay
gotcha
i can hear her
in my ear
she's breathing
hmm
how do we get out there
nope
i'm not looking i'm not looking
i need a key no i don't okay
oh
oh don't eat them
there was no way the flashbang grenades
were standard power company equipment
let's get rid of all this gun
clean up the town you know
be a good citizen and all that oh sh
really stepped in that one
wait
can i take this car
no
balls well why is it here then
like i really could okay fine
bye gentee thanks for coming
can't see can't see this blooms
christ you get i guess
it's gonna be low guys one second please
one two [ __ ]
okay reload and just one left
get used useless now
i think you wheel them down
and then it's three shots and they're
dead
as long as you have enough distance
so they can't get around you behind you
because they're very good at that
then it's not so bad
big boy
oh god
whoa this is getting foggy now
at least the the uh papers
are extremely emissive
so you can't really miss them
i stared through the bars of the jail
cell barry stood behind me swaying on
his feet looking as ill as i felt
agent nightingale stood on the other
side of the bars with sheriff breaker
nightingale had a stack of manuscript
pages in his hand
he seemed unhinged as he gloated well
i've got you now raymond chandler it's
all here all the evidence including
conspiracy to murder a federal agent
okay
so we're gonna run back into the police
boys later
oh yeah the the shotgun definitely would
have worked better mark but i am saving
that for the
yeah for
serious times
although we're quite well stocked up i
still want to save it for when i feel i
need it the most
we're gonna go up here because dots
i don't know why but this noise reminds
me of like batman arkham games
it really sounds like batman now that
i'm thinking of it
come on i cannot be the only one batman
arkham i think like the first game maybe
[Music]
yes
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] em
oh no
oh no
okay now
oh god
okay now we can go
oh god
oh [ __ ]
that's too busy thinking about batman
right
uh
where am i
oh yeah just go up there
dude
oh my god all i can hear is batman now
[Music]
dude yeah infinite bliss exactly
arkham asylum
i swear this just sounds exactly like it
okay
they're also spread out [ __ ] hate it
so hard to get them with this [ __ ]
light
all right and then run here so you can
have some leverage from leeway [ __ ]
actually maybe i can just [ __ ] run
away just went away
[ __ ] these guys
they're not they're not worth it alan
they're not worth it
just go
whoa [ __ ] jesus christ
okay maybe they are
oh my god how many [ __ ] shots mate
are you [ __ ] me
all right now
he's already like lit up
i just got an achievement
gun scribe what
oh
[Music]
no i'm back to having [ __ ] all ammo wha
what happened i was doing so well
fine
uh so where
where now
so came down here
then i decided to go
maybe i went too far back yeah i think i
did yeah yeah i did
go back to the ammo crate
oh no that's so far back nah
they'll also probably respawn
which i do not want
would they respond hmm
maybe i could go all the way back that's
so far back though i don't even know if
it's possible
no [ __ ] i can't be asked
can't be asked got to finish this
chapter before bedtime
oh please don't fall alan allen
oh my gosh oh there's a yeah there
you've been [ __ ] off
these controls
pick up the thermos crate
how are you doing this
okay
mark well that was epic
he
thanks
walking on air
there
so something at least
at least we're stocked up on batteries i
mean that's that's something as well
are we all do we need to reload here
yeah
i had no real plan i was going to give
the kidnapper all the manuscript pages i
had for alice if that wasn't enough i'd
hold him at gunpoint and make him talk
wait what's this
pump action
okay
yes
i say yes
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
i'm scared
oh
yay
no
just going to make it to the light she's
going to make it to the light
oh [ __ ] that it's in the wrong way
i don't want it to turn off i don't want
it to turn off
ah how are you okay out here there's a
light there can you not see it
thank [ __ ] christ for that
they seem to be fine with that light
though
that's concerning
okay maybe i will get the big boys out
yeah don't care don't care just let me
let me turn on this light
let me turn on the light i'm pressing
okay thank you
yes
to die alan wake shadow slayer
oh let me in that holy light
and let alone catch his breath
maybe they started wearing sunglasses
oh if
maybe they did oh focus
[Music]
the dark presence was moving ahead of me
in the same direction i was going a cold
feeling settled itself in the pit of my
stomach i'm also ready for alice
i've been a graveyard
okay that's uh that's a hot take sir oh
[ __ ] off he's been [ __ ] really fast
fast boy
faster than me boys
oh god joe don't you stabby stab stab me
i've stabbed my stab stab you sir
i won't actually i'll show you shoot you
oh [ __ ] you i hate i'll speak fast one
time
fast boy
thank you
daddy
did i die let me in the toilet please
i don't know if it's a toilet
anything around here any pages anything
fun no well i'm gonna go because i i
never know
how spawning works in this game it just
seems like sometimes they're just
a never-ending spawning forever ah
that's nice
batteries i don't want batteries i
i want ammo
i thought i was doing so well
the place was dead a ghost town had been
for decades maybe a century
what the [ __ ]
excuse me
can you stop that please
is there anything down there
no
what the hell
i don't want a spooky car
lucky it went over us
can we get in here and find any ammos
[Music]
it's herbie oh my gosh that's a blast
from the fast mark
why my little friend used to love her
never as simple in real life as in
fiction
i had lost count of the times i had
wished there'd be a clear reason for my
writer's block something to fight
something to lash out on
there wasn't
i was filled with doubt i was nothing
like the hero in my books alex casey had
gone through his life with single-minded
determination never wavering from his
goal even now i was angry at myself
angry at alice angry at barry i was
fumbling and i had no plan
it's okay
we always think that everyone else
knows what they're doing or you know so
much more confident than we are but
probably about the same
great peak george originally founded in
1928 the great peak george mining gorge
sorry mining town was one of the
permanent settlements the bright force
mining company built for its workers the
nearby graveyard is a testament to the
dangers the miners face on a daily basis
most of the men who lost their lives
over the years here were buried there a
grim reminder to be careful for those
who remained
great peak gorge was abandoned almost
overnight but the bright falls mining
company closed its doors in 1970.
great yeah well had a lovely uh
experience down in the graveyard
very happy i went there
where would there be
ammunition
if i were ammo
where would i be
in one of these
excuse me don't please have growl at me
a coverage named george won't be meta af
yeah
george
the georgie goji
oh i don't want coffee
oh i don't want to eat [ __ ] batteries
i want amma
i can't believe he's giving me bloody
batteries
and i need ammo
[ __ ]
ah
yes batteries are good against haunted
bridges though
okay fell it fell it fell
she fell over the fridge fell over
such a weird
mechanic
let you catch your breath
can you make bombs out of
coffee and battery acid or are you just
saying that
whoa
dude that was so close ah
you know what i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm
actually gonna go back and i'm gonna
pick up those
pick up those uh thingies oh thank you
so much fargo doggo
what did you say what did you say you're
doing great
thank you thank you for the support i
appreciate it
it's very nice of you
okay what come at me
come at me is it gonna be you barrel
this scared me
they take so much
okay
that's good
that's good
we've we've got to be we've got to be
nearing the end of it now surely
what's that oh a key i've got a key
do we have to go in here oh no it's not
blocked okay
oh coffee hello
uh fedor front door there you are
quite hidden
looks quite nice in here
anything outside of riding is a struggle
i feel ill
i managed to make my way downstairs
there's a shoe box filled with books and
papers by thomas zane it's very hard to
focus but i managed to read some of it
he's a poet and a good one he writes of
muses and creators summoning fabulous
things from a magic lake using his
powers to shape the world of a realm of
gods and dreams and demons dark things
that wait for a chance to slip through
wearing the flesh of men as disguise
zane writes about himself
his girlfriend being taken over by a
dark presence
about growing scared of the lake
zane believes it's a mirror to the
gaping void of darkness above where some
lovecraftian presence lurks
i crawl back upstairs
i'll borrow these things for my story
they ring true
they fit
he's basically finishing off what the
other writers started that's that's so
cool though i love that premise
of like muses and poets are being used
by a darker force
sure i'll take i'll take this
this is just real life
is this just fair to see
okay okay that's my cue to leave
oh
hello the kidnapper had sent me a text
the message was full of spelling errors
and insults he was telling me to hurry
up
smelling errors and insults
but he is too english to say what those
insults was
far too hurtful
nice
thank you very much
cool
that's everything
let's try out this new gun when we get a
chance
[Music]
ah thank you so much infinite bliss
awesome stream so much fun i'm glad
you're enjoying it i'm glad you're
enjoying my
my
cries of anguish oh wrong button i
didn't mean to press that uh
get out of here
zoom
birds
[Applause]
even birds are evil in this game
do i just go for it
oh good
he didn't even leave he was just like
all derpy
gotcha [ __ ]
danger danger
okay we made it
well this is not claustrophobic
is the day time now
yeah what
what mate
you want me
is this the right way
without warning the headache stabbed in
my brain
alice
alice
whoa
i'm losing it i gotta get out of
here where's the page there
the hunters were big thick set men
confident and at home in the woods they
were feeling good running on beard ghost
stories and camaraderie late into the
night
it did them no good as they were taken
by the dark presence sucked deep into a
darkness far worse than any ghost story
they ever told or heard
okay are these the people that we're
killing
i'm guessing we don't jump in here right
that would be a stupid thing to do
surely
gotta go back up and then turn left
because i only came down here because i
heard her like whispering
allen's name
what is that picture death i have no
idea what that is i can still see
something really tiny it's like the
close-up of someone's face
okay let's keep going through here
nice nice nice
i'm never gonna say no to that
ah [ __ ]
how do they get behind you so [ __ ]
quickly like it's just not fair
oh
oh god
okay this weapon's good
i like i like it i like a bit loud
even behind the closed doors and
curtains of his grimy room at the
majestic the local motel
nightingale could feel the local's eyes
on him the unrelenting pressure of their
judgment
he forced it out of his mind for all he
knew they could all be under awake's
spell already you do what you have to do
to get the job done
he took comfort from the bottle in his
hand please he thought
just let me get through this okay so
he's like working for
the dark falls
and he's drinking to getting through it
but
you still have to look at yourself
afterwards you can't stay drunk all the
time
where do we go now
we're down
the only way we can go
oh coffee
hmm
i'd have to make my way up this mine
shaft in order to go on
maybe the machinery could help me with
that
okay
here's a chance don't [ __ ] it up
like that
[ __ ]
where am i going now over there
okay
yes
something like that
oh cool
that was good
nice little level design right there
not keeping it all the same
mixing it up a little bit
but not making you backtrack
what's down here
oh
no
yeah jeff it's
20 past 11. it's way past my bedtime but
i want to get i want to finish this
episode
because i keep thinking like it must be
nearly done now
do i want to go up or down i don't know
that was a good choice
lightning flashed behind the windows of
cauldron lake lodge tore anderson
laughed and held the steel hammer above
his head
nurse sinclair was trying to calm him
down without success
tor grinned madly and shouted my
hammer's up here's a friendly poke from
mullner wench
he brought the hammer down with all his
might on sinclair's head we're on a
comeback tour baby
wait what
mon yeah isn't that thor's hammer
i might be wrong tell me if i'm wrong
but isn't that thor's hammer
lightning flash
what
tour saw so does someone think that he's
thought or is he actually supposed to be
like thought
i think he's just gone mad and he thinks
he's thought cause he's called tor
i don't know
that's so weird
okay cool
oh that's very nice
look at that see this isn't even
remastered how pretty is that
that's just the game showing off right
there it's like hey look at us we made a
pretty game
oh yeah he's telling a story but what
happens in the story what's so
interesting about finding the story
is that it a lot of what you read about
if not all i think everything you read
about
is what's happening right now so it
could be the past the present the future
so you might read something that in the
game happens in the future so like we
read
a
note about the bulldozer um about to
kill us and then that happened you know
about half an hour or so later so
that's what's pretty interesting about
finding those
those notes
[Applause]
[Applause]
the sound of that
is really good
like
i can hear the screams
of the human screams coming from the
birds cries
and you know having her like breathe in
your ear whenever you're near
an ammo station and stuff it's just so
cool
okay
we got a flare gun if anything
goes awry
where these birds at
[ __ ] sake
come on
as long as they know where they are i'm
fine
are they flying away
um
[Applause]
[Music]
are you okay
okay
[Music]
allen's fine don't worry
oh gosh maybe not for long though
[Applause]
now we're all good we are good
[ __ ] off
jesus [ __ ]
that was close
that was really close
i don't want to shoot it i don't want to
waste any ammo
although we're not doing too badly but
yeah still
okay
keep going
i feel like i'm in the zone right now
i'm just
you know
just racing it towards the end towards
the finish line come on
we got this
what's gonna happen now
i wonder
what oh crapping jesus
is this the way it just came from i sure
hope not
okay
reloading
good go go go go go go go go go go good
which way did i come from
uh oh yeah yellow dot yellow dot yellow
dot we remember
yellow dot
oh oh over here
i see you
nowhere
thank you
i don't think it's this way
i can see a page down here
mod had checked all of stuckey's rental
cabins
there had been no sign of the wakes
it was dark when you'd found their car
parked at the end of the road by
cauldron lake it made no sense
they must have taken a wrong turn but
there was no sign of them and the car
had been there for hours already
frustrated mott stood on the rotten ruin
of the foot bridge that had once led to
divers aisle before it sank beneath the
waves years ago
the boss wouldn't be happy
okay so that was him finding us
initially see that was like way in the
past mud
definitely having them all there and it
looks like they're put in order as well
just really help you understand this
game because reading them a bit out of
order gets a little bit confusing
kick kick
kick it bop it
push it
pull it
jump it
oh no fake door
oh spooky spooky spooky spooky
but it looks like we have to go there oh
coffee
great
tom
oh my gosh it's the first
writer who was you know in love with you
talk to me on tv tom
i miss you tom did you write this
tom tom
did you write this of course tom didn't
write this
okay the lights in my room have just
turned off
and i don't know why it's kind of
okay
the background now that was weird
it's entering my room the scariness
is this like a little grave for tom or
something
c w and t z
am i missing something here i thought
tom was with
someone called barbara i am i've
definitely missed something here
i cursed you domine
i miss you i curse you there's some love
hate stuff going on here
so
okay we're getting ready for another big
big big fight
of course
in the same room that we just wearing
lovely baby
yeah and take another one
whoa
i'm playing around no more
i ain't gonna stroke your ego
okay
where's that coffee
there it is
it
i love how jasmine became a killer ghost
yeah it seemed to be like doing okay now
right i don't want to jokes myself but
i'm doing not too bad not too shabby not
too shabby
i could see cauldron lake i thought i
could make out the spot where the island
and the cabin had been there was a light
near it it had to be a boat
i was close now i had to get there fast
i dreaded what i would find wait is that
no we just ran past a note come on alan
i know you're going fast but we gotta
read you're a writer you can't just walk
past paper with words on it i tried to
hold on to alice but her form melted
away
i was losing control
dr hartman stood in her place
i wanted to hit him but my arms were
jelly he smiled it was a reassuring
smile and i hated him for it
i had to give you a sedative don't fight
it you went through another rough period
right now it's very important that you
stay calm
we don't want you to have another
episode you're a patient at my clinic
have been for a while now
okay so what like he thought
he saw alice but then
turns out it wasn't it was just a doctor
and maybe that's how we're gonna wake up
from
wait i don't know
hey i'm here i'm coming
no get away sorry please
the boss didn't know who he was messing
with i i didn't know i swear i didn't
know
we don't know where she
you is they got a lighting for us
please
i'm sorry oh so he's got nothing to do
with this
okay
oh yeah
we read about this
[Applause]
oh
oh [ __ ] so she was dragged into the
water
nice
[Music]
that is the end of episode
okay thank you so much for watching
that was a long one
every episode is so freaking hectic
isn't it um but extremely fun and it
looks like you are all enjoying uh this
as well i'm bad we're all having good
time here it's good it's good fun um
if you did not know
uh i do have a discord so if no one is
or if anybody here isn't in the discord
who wants to be i'll put a little
invitation in the chat it's also in the
in the description down below as well
um but i will
put a little link here now
uh
and yeah
i keep you up to date on like when i'm
streaming if any videos coming out
anything like that but i will stream
every thursday at 8 30 pm gmt so
the next episode episode 4 will
be
coming out or we'll be live next
thursday so next week
um
but yeah thanks everyone now that was a
fun stream indeed no way has it
thank you i'm glad you enjoyed you did
pretty well this time thanks
i feel like i just cause i like play
games but obviously i just played like
once a week it takes me like half an
hour or something just get back into the
controls and you're like the gist of
things and then when i start to pick it
back up i'm like okay okay okay i got
this i got this
ah thanks for watching kastara's
castawoos
but yeah i mean this game does make me
extremely angry at times but apparently
that's entertaining so it's all good as
long as it helps
it helps the entertainment value then
it's all good by me
all right i'm going to say goodbye to
who i can see in the chat now so goodbye
um mark goodbye 8.96 goodbye nelson
goodbye
death157 goodbye nowhere jose goodbye
clay even though you just got back okay
goodbye clay goodbye casteroos
um
anyone else goodnight infinite bliss and
good night froggodoggo
and good night to anyone who i have
missed in the chat and as always good
night to anybody who is watching but
isn't in the chat i really appreciate
you being here
so
have a lovely day or evening i'll see
you next thursday 8 30 pm gmt
and